Speaker 1: I want to go over something sort
of in more detail that is really important
to understand because I'm now getting a ton
of emails about it.
I want to devote its own segment to it rather
than just mentioning it as an aside.
And what I want to talk about is the bogus
reporting in Florida of covid deaths that
no matter when you look, it looks like deaths
are declining so rapidly in Florida, things
must be going super well in Florida.
If you look at the death charts and Florida
has figured out a way to report deaths, that
it always creates a downward decline.
Downward decline doesn't make a steep decline.
And I want to explain to you exactly how it
works.
There's actually an article about this in
the Miami Herald.
Florida changed its covid data, creating an
artificial decline in recent deaths.
And the article explains exactly how it works.
As cases ballooned in August, the Florida
Department of Health changed the way it reported
death data to the CDC, giving the appearance
of a pandemic in decline.
On Monday, Florida death data would have shown
would have shown an average of two hundred
and sixty two daily deaths over the previous
week under the former reporting system.
Instead, the Monday update from Florida showed
just 46 new deaths per day over the previous
seven days.
The dramatic difference is due to a small
change in the fine print.
This is the key part.
Until three weeks ago, data collected and
published on the CDC website counted deaths
by the day they were recorded a common method
for producing daily stats used by most states.
On Aug. 10, Florida switched its methodology
and, along with just a handful of other states,
began to tally new deaths by the date the
person died.
If you chart deaths by Florida's new method
based on date of death, it will generally
appear even during a spike like the present,
that deaths are on a recent downslope.
That's because it takes time for deaths to
be evaluated and death certificates to be
processed.
When the deaths finally are tallied, they
are then assigned to the actual date of death,
creating a spike where there was a downslope
in the past.
This is let me paraphrase this.
OK, here is what the chart of Florida deaths
look like.
And you see that absolutely massive downslope.
What is happening is if it takes longer than
seven days for a death to show up in the totals,
it's not included in the current seven day
average.
So when you delay assigning the deaths to
a specific day, at least a week, when you
look at the last seven days, there's almost
no deaths there.
And that causes this massive decline.
Current deaths, recent deaths will always
look low because it's taking you a week or
more to assign to those deaths to a date.
This is extraordinarily disingenuous.
And when you look at the seven day average,
it looks as though they're over the peak.
They're seeing this big decline.
And then on day eight, you assign the deaths
today.
One, they're now outside of the seven day
average.
You look back at that day that said 40 deaths.
Now it says two hundred and sixty or whatever
the number was.
And you're constantly pushing the spike back
a week in time.
Extraordinarily disingenuous.
This should come as a surprise to no one who
is outside of the right wing news bubble.
Florida has been a disaster run dissent.
This has been a disaster.
But what's really wacky is could this be a
method that helps run decision to get reelected
in twenty twenty to one of the top twenty
twenty two races?
In my mind, in terms of implications for four,
is the gubernatorial race in Florida, not
only because Ron de Santos as governor in
twenty four is more likely to participate
in the voter hijinx, et cetera, but also because
it would be a signal about the state of Florida
in terms of how it is likely to vote.
The Florida gubernatorial race, one of the
most important twenty, twenty two races.
We are going to engage with that race.
We're going to get people activated on that
for sure.
And in terms of people.
Oh, I'll mention that just because we're talking
about it.
I've been getting emails about like when do
I think our twenty, twenty two coverage is
going to ramp up historically the interest
in.
It terms starts around March, April.
I think it's going to be earlier this year
because of the stakes, because of the pandemic,
because of a lot of different things, including
the fact that this is the first referendum,
November of 2002 is when we will see, ah,
was it a was it an error by voters to elect
people like Marjorie Taylor Green and Madison
Cawthorn and others and their goal?
And are they going to be removed at the first
opportunity, which would be next November,
November of 2002?
Or is this movement, this Magga Klown movement
here to stay?
And are we going to see some of those people
reelected?
So this is a big deal mid-term.
And I expect even though normally it gets
going in March, April, it's probably going
to be more like February would be
my guess